the chill of New Hampshire can freeze
presidential ambition niiki Haley is
trying to generate heat in a campaign
Republican voters have so far treated as
lukewarm if she wants to win the
Republican primary here she has to
convince voters she can beat Trump and
beat Biden she has to convince voters
like Marie Corgan who went for one last
check before making a final decision on
who gets her support in the primary I'm
burning from Nikki Haley because she
really checks a lot of my you know I
want they want fiscal responsibility but
I do want somebody who is compassionate
and we have several CL you know
candidates that are running who I don't
think have dipped their toe in the milk
of kindness for a very long time and are
very abrasive and they they're
flamethrowers prosecutors are out of
control but Donald Trump is ahead in the
Republican race despite his troubles
elsewhere 91 indictments over four
criminal cases but when here it it all
but seals the nomination Trump is
essentially you know weaponized his
shamelessness he's argued that every
indictment is a conspiracy to get him
it's an effort to bring him down it's a
sign that Democrats are afraid of him
and so on uh and uh he's essentially
said if you're Republican you have to be
with me for the Democrats there's
essentially no contest there's a primary
but in a row over timings no delegates
will be awarded the National Party
counts South Carolina as the first
proper primary I am so opposed to the
current administration's stand on the
ceasefire but one of Biden's policies is
on the ballot his backing of Israel's
war in Gaza and one group is urging a
protest on ballot forms we veto the UN
Human Rights resolution uh for human
humanitarian ceasefire um but you can't
veto my vote Nikki Haley set high
expectations in New Hampshire but every
poll puts Donald Trump significantly
ahead the reality is unless there's a
huge shock at the polls Nikki Haley is
in the final hours of our presidential
campaign Alan fiser Al jazer
Manchester make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer